valium because it is heavier has two
different so-called oxidation states you
can either it can react with one atom of
chlorine potassium or say three and the
difference chemistry between thallium 1
and thallium 3 thallium salts are very
poisonous and there was quite a
notorious case some years ago when a
technician at some company who turned
out to be mad was discovered to have
been poisoning many of his colleagues
with thallium and so but it is not a
widely used element apart from a few
materials that use that there is a
rather nice red material that is made of
thallium which has the rather unromantic
name of Krsna amide and iodine of
thallium which is used as Windows for
many infrared experiments but because
thallium is so poisonous one has to be
quite careful about handling